Slow your scroll.
Elon Musk said over the weekend
that Twitter will limit,
at least temporarily,
the number of posts you can read.
He claims it's an effort
to address
extreme levels of data scraping,
so verified accounts
limited to 10,000 posts
per day,
unverified accounts 1000 per day.
And this was revealed
after thousands of users
complained that they were unable
or had trouble accessing the site.
Many reported
getting messages
that they had exceeded their rate limit.
So what is behind this latest turmoil
for the company?
CNN's senior
media analyst Sarah Fischer joins us.
She's also senior media reporter
at Axios.
And Sara, what gives what now with him?
There's always something, Audie,
that was a dull day in Elon Musk land.
You know,
I think this is a response
to the rise of a lot of big A.I.
platforms
that are starting to scrape
big social media platforms
for data to help train their algorithms.
You saw Reddit
a few weeks ago
said that they would start
to charging developers
for some of that back and to access.
They got a lot of pushback
from their community.
It seems like Elon Musk
is trying to do something similar.
But the difference, Audie, is
that this is going to have
a huge impact
on the everyday users
experience with Twitter.
You saw some people
tweeting frustration yesterday,
ironically tweeting frustration
about Twitter.
That they weren't able
to get severe
weather updates, critical news
and information
because they were being limited
to the number of posts
that they were able to view.
Now, Elon Musk has not said
how long he's going to implement
this temporary crackdown,
but I do know that it's going
to be frustrating for advertisers
because they're reliant
on have the usage
in order to fulfill their ad campaigns,
make sure they have enough people
watching and reading tweets
in order to insert their ads
between them,
theoretically reliant
on them for business.
But one quick fact check,
what's this about
maybe him not paying his bills.
Can you talk about what's going on there?
There have been so many reports,
whether it's been submitted
to B2B vendors or its licensing or its
leases, if you will, that Twitter
has struggled to pay its bills.
And that's because Twitter
is really struggling
with profitability right now.
Now, to be honest,
Twitter has always struggled
with profitability
even before Elon Musk took over.
But the difference is
that they are not
a publicly traded company.
They do not need to be transparent
about their finances,
what money they're bringing in
and what money they're spending
And so it seems like
the company is
just in this sort of chaotic spot
where it's trying to stay afloat,
but it's not necessarily doing it
in the most transparent way.
We keep getting reports
not also just about not paying bills,
but they're still in litigation
with former employees
about paying out severance, etc.
So expect
Twitter to continue
to be
in the sort of financial chaos
until maybe they
can turn the platform around.
But I'm still skeptical, Audie,
even though they have
put in
a new chief executive,
this platform continues to be chaos.
As I cover it.
All right, Sara, stay with us.
I want to bring Shelby and Earl back in.
You're so jealous that you didn't write
the program
is broadcast worthy to be right there.
I think
why I love listening to Sarah talk about
this is because I'm fascinated
by the business story.
Less, less on the myopic
like Navel-gazing
people being angry about their tweets
not being available
and all that sort of stuff.
But from a business perspective,
they bring in Linda Marino,
a big time executive.
It's supposed to juice up their
advertising and,
you know, I'm
asking Elon Musk, how does this end?
Well, it's not going to be pretty.
At this point,
the estimate is that under Elon Musk,
the company has lost
two thirds of its value.
He paid $44 billion for it.
It's worth something like 50 billion.
And that's not good. Right?
Right. Right, right.
Not good.
It's not going to be
the number to go in the other direction.
The fact that advertisers
and important users
like the National Weather Service
and others are saying like this,
this may not be for us
the algorithm
is it still sort of promotes and favors,
you know, kind of anger and division
and outrage,
making it
a much less pleasant user experience.
For everybody who's left on it.
And then this idea
that you're going to get out of it
by paying eight bucks,
which has just been roundly rejected,
they've got very, very few subscribers
even among their daily users.
So as a business,
it just seems to be falling apart.
Now, it's it's
got a lot of sort of potential.
It's got a lot of residual affection.
It's got a lot of users apolitical tool.
Right.
We have 20, 24 coming up.
I mean, do campaigns
think they're going to
still be using Twitter?
Yeah, I think well,
I think the big thing is
if it was just this change,
it would be a huge change.
But given how much Elon Musk
has already changed the platform,
like I know
personally, I feel like
the platform is a little bit
less reliable
now in terms of me finding verified news
that has been fact-checked
and is legitimate And so I think
in that sense,
it's a little bit less of a priority
for campaigns.
I mean, Donald Trump
is still not on the platform,
for example.
I do think
pre Elon Musk,
he would have more of a reason
to join it.
Sir, with the time we have left,
I mean, from a business perspective,
from a one day
Carino perspective,
do that
when you talk to both people
inside the company,
but also analysts outside?
Is there a pathway that exists here
to kind of get them out of this
just constant
state of tumult and seeming collapse,
followed by resuscitation,
followed by some new
strategy that I can't figure out
there is a pathway.
One of
the things that you're going to hear
internally a lot
is that Linda brings assurance
to the talent inside.
There's still some people
who are great salespeople,
who are great engineers
that want
just guidance and direction
and some assurance that things aren't
going to change that much.
And they're hoping that Linda
will bring some consistency.
But from the outside world,
the perspective of the advertisers
and marketers,
I just spent a good week
with them
at a big advertising festival overseas.
And the thing that you keep hearing is
that Twitter is still the most relevant
public square for political discourse.
You have media,
which is the parent company
that Instagram and Facebook
that's trying to build out a rival.
You have small budding
rivals like Mastodon and Blue Sky.
But at the end of the day, Twitter
is still the biggest public square
in the world.
And so if Elon Musk can figure this out,
there's definitely a product
case to be made for it being relevant.
I'm just not quite sure, quite frankly,
if he's going to be able to do it
and keep Linda Guarino at his side
and she doesn't get too frustrated
and just leave.
Yeah.
It's fascinating to
watch it all play out.
Sara, thanks as always
for the great reporting. I.